but i'm just so proud to be here and
you're just so proud to be there
how great is it that we live in a world
where love
self-esteem diversity and inclusion can
be celebrated
so let's get out there and poverty and
remember i'll be
two doors down just living and drinking
and having a party
tonight to pm prize stands for power and
purpose we are here to amplify power to
end discrimination
and our purpose is doing it right now
we're united in this fight across every
intersectional identity
loving every bit of ourselves and taking
so much pride in who we are and we're
going to keep opening doors for each
other hello everyone
this is ricky martin it means so much to
me to be part of can't cancel pride
again this year especially as we have so
much
to reflect on so many lives lost to
cover
and to violence that takes many forms
[Music]
[Applause]
jojo i want to congratulate you on
sharing yourself with the world and
coming out this year
i'm overjoyed you have joined our
beautiful community
at 17 you were able to do something that
took people of my generations
decades to do not only are you living
your truth
you're a shining example to young people
the world over
and their families by showing that love
is love and people are people
and that is that this pride we've got to
make sure
everybody gets the respect they deserve
that's the art
i'm about today when the queen of soul
aretha franklin saying r-e-s-p-e-c-t
she was singing for and to all of us the
lgbtqi
plus community black and brown people
indigenous folks
our aapi sisters and brothers i'm here
to put the i
am pride individuality and
intersectionality
the lgbtq community is filled with
amazing individuals of
every background and ability but even as
individuals
we do not stand alone as a queer person
it is very
important to me to stand with black
lives matter black trans lives matter
stop aapi hate and other groups that
speak truth to power
hey i'm brandi carlisle and i'm so
honored to join all of these incredible
lgbtq plus artists and allies
who are sharing a message of acceptance
and pride tonight
i believe music creates change and i
know it brings us strength and joy
tell me that the world's been spinning
since the beginning
and everything will be alright
burns but i
[Music]
died
[Music]
gonna
my dance
you